dear brothers
and sisters
always
several brothers and sisters
ask me this question
a brother who is married
to
to a christian woman
recently asked me
if he is allowed to force her
to become a muslim
the answer
to this question
is found in this ayah of the quran in
surah
which means
there is no compulsion
in religion
guidance
has become clear from falsehood
this ayah
shows us
that it is not permissible to first
islam
on anyone
this negates
the honor which allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has
bestowed
upon mankind
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
which means
we have surely honored
the children
of
adam
the scholars
have explained this ayah
shows that shows that islam is a clear
religion
if the proof of islam is brought to
someone
with a sound mind
they will enter islam on their own
with allah's guidance
and
whoever is
misguided
should not be forced
this is
this is the meaning
of the ayah
guidance has become clear from falsehood
there is no reason
to behave differently with those who are
not muslim
when you do business with them
you must
fulfill
their rights
if a muslim does not fulfill the rights
of a non-muslim
this is
a con
a contradiction
of the teachings of the quran
it is also
in contradiction to the example of our
messenger
allah
a good example
of the
of the proper
behavior with non-muslims
is in this story
of
once a non-muslim woman
came to
him asking for money
before umar lovelier
gave her the money
he invited her to islam
saying
become a muslim and you will have peace
truly
allah has sent
muhammad allah
in the truth
the women
refused and
allah her money before she left
but
then he feared
that he was
taking advantage of the women's
position because she needed something
from him
he asked allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala forgiveness
and
pray to allah saying
oh allah
i call to your religion
and i did not force anyone
please dear brothers move forward
and also we have two two rooms here you
can enter brothers
dear brothers and sisters
this is
example of the freedom
of religion in islam
a muslim can offer and explain islam
but
this
should not be done in forth
and forceful manner
there has been
much
discussion among the scholars about the
way for
a muslim man to speak to his non-muslim
wife about islam
this is
something that should be addressed
in the
marriage contract
however
some scholars
believe
that
requiring
a wife to become a muslim is a type of
pleasure
imam shafiri
said
this
should not be in the marriage contract
the hanafi
scholars
said
a muslim
a muslim man should call his wife
to islam
but
not force her to accept it
this proves
the owner plays on each person in islam
and the honor plays
on women
which means
if they accept islam
then they have choosing guidance and you
are only responsible for
delivering the message
allah wa ta'ala is well aware
of his servants
the question
that we must not
ask is
why does islam place
so much importance on freedom
of religion
first of all
first of all islam is a religion that
was revealed by the almighty
through
his messenger
muhammad allah
which means
truly the religion in the
sight of allah is islam
our prophet salallahu
was sent to all of mankind and does not
say anything out of his own wounds
this is
divinely revealed speech
secondly
it is important
to
note
that the differences in religion is a
matter that comes from the will of allah
allah subhanahu wa
says
which means
if you are lord
so will
everyone
on earth
would believe
shall you
shall you first people so that they will
believe
these
these verses
show that it is not
permitted
to force people to accept islam
because it goes against the will of
allah
finally
because
allah
created man
as a thinking being
differences in belief are bound to
happen
which means if your lord so will
he would have met
mankind all our nation
all one nation
but
they differ
among themselves
except he
who has your lord's mercy upon him
he created them for this purpose
the word of your lord is final that he
will fill
the hell fire with jinn and mankind
together
we must
dear brothers and sisters
we must have a deep understanding that
it is from the will of
allah that humanity is
is capable capable
of
both faith
and disbelief
it is
from the
gift of allah
that we are
rational
beings
allah says
truly we have guided him
he will
either be
grateful or any great or
ungrateful
for this reason
to
infringe
on the freedom of belief
is the same as
to infringe
on
human dignity
or to influence
on the dignity of this religion of truth
by
making it a matter of convulsion
rather than
discussion
and
conviction
allah says
which means
do you not think deeply
about
the quran
and quran
or allah
make us among those who speak a word of
truth
and follow the best of it
and make us
people of guidance worthy of
guiding others
allah
[Silence]
foreign